it's time for roses and Rose a I'm tan
it's hot summer hi guys I don't know how
uneven my makeup looks because I got a
little bit of Sun since I've last seen
you over the old 4th of July weekend and
guess what I did not find you concealer
how is it how's the contouring how's the
under eye situation kind of rough we're
moving forward though so guys we missed
a week and we're back and I love this
episode Ryan
Peter and Dean all got one on one and
Matt and Adam we don't really remember
them they weren't happy about it no one
is safe that's the truth right now
nothing is guaranteed so yeah Matt and
Adam madam as I'm calling them we're
like why are we here and you know what
we'll get to that there's a good
question again I don't even remember in
Europe where we are anymore cobblestone
streets beautiful architecture is rich
in history so breathtaking cobblestone
an architecture that's literally all of
Europe I don't mean to sound healing
form but that could be anywhere of
course we have to go to a watch store oh
we're in Switzerland watches great so
this is Brian's one on one and while
Brian is on any one on one the other
guys are like be the broom and be the
broom that just sweeps her off her feet
yeah you got a B in the broom sweep
Robert yeah
so first drinking game of the night
while they're all talking Peter is
rocking eat eat that is as gray as his
cell Deborah ham and they're both
equally glorious tonight you guys drink
every time Peter wears gray you know
what works for me stick with him no ham
flour black all the time
slimming brian is on his one-on-one with
Rachel and Dean is questioning Brian and
this there's a lot to me because Dean
question leads and was right about Lea
and Deena smart so you know raise your
red flag about Brian I just still think
that Brian is too much about the fairy
tale right now it's coming across as
Brian seems like he's too good to be
true and then he made this comment about
Rachel and a schoolgirl uniform I want a
uniform a little cooler office no no
it's not okay Brian not okay don't ever
say that again
so even rachel is questioning Brian I
mean another drinking game drink every
times how many questions Brian but still
she wants the fairy tale and she's like
this feels like a fairy tale on
detective guess because you're in a
castle don't be blinded by the cackle I
feel like I'm in a fairy tale he makes
me feel like I'm definitely his presence
pass the stone into Brian see this heart
of stone okay I should write a book so
by the way Rachel is looking fabulous
this entire episode she is serving like
some Jackie O ambassador for our great
nation
look loved it the bachelor nation
stylist is Cary fattening you guys
follow him on Instagram he's wandering
okay then we have a one-on-one with Dean
you'll notice a pattern here
the guys who got one on ones were Brian
Dean and Peter and they feel like the
frontrunners don't they they do yeah so
Dean got this date where they like went
to church and then they dance in the
street okay and you know Dean during the
dinner
[Music]
he was like today was weird seeing again
thank you for your honesty it was weird
it was weird
we love you but it was weird okay but
rachel says deep Pokemon feelings
hmm we're in this weird situation but I
still have to get to know you and Rachel
keeps the 100 that's why I love her
again play weird why
and then Dean kept it really real and
told this very painful story about what
the loss of his mom did to his family my
family is not going to be the family
that you want to see and he just gave us
some foreshadowing for hometown and
scene I love you Dean is great I don't
think he's going to be the bachelor and
I don't think Rachel's gonna pick him
but I do think we're going to see him in
paradise I love Dean okay Dean
will you accept the truth hmm I think
voters so Dean gets a rose shocker
and Rachel gave us a little leg pop
during the kiss romantic I love it okay
Peter's one-on-one so Rachel's like
reminder I like you and Peter's like
reminder the feelings that we had
originally are still there I like you
too and Peter's wearing that sweater
that is as salt and pepper as his hair
drinks Peters brain gray again Peter
also wore gray another time when they're
having a conversation about getting a
drink for that you know what drink every
time somebody had a really intense
conversation not about me during this
episode out of this whole group everyone
there's already gone one except us too I
don't know maybe it was like it spends a
lot of money on getting all these
different locations they just had to
keep the guys to this one hotel room in
this balcony because they were on the
balcony so much nobody jump yeah okay so
Peters in Greg Greg Greg
I mean is he Fifty Shades of Grey
well mr. Gracey you know it's either
going to be the bachelor you guys or she
gonna take him I don't know I would be
fine with either outcome I think you
make a great bachelor so they go in the
snow and oh my god
then he served us with messy windblown
snow decorated upon it salt-and-pepper
hair I don't even know who I am anymore
okay okay okay I'm good okay remember
Matt and Adam yep nope nobody did but
they were there and they're talking to
and then Peter was honest with Rachel so
Brian has been honest Dean has been
honest and results Amy honestly scares
her this year was Peter tonight his
honesty scares me Rachel which way do
you want it bottom line is this we we
need to figure out who's being the most
honest in this weird situation that is
so natural so Peters holding on to some
guilts let it go Rachel's afraid of the
honesty and go in for the kiss and they
did I love it and I don't throw around
or love easily
it's definitely along a path that is the
perfect balance of sincerity with
romance that's not fairy tale crap
Peter so then to no one's surprise Erik
and Adam and Matt have to go on this
like weird date work summer talked a lot
before tomorrows decision was gonna be
difficult and I look at the word
difficult I'm like I thought where I
don't like that word because I don't
think anything is difficult to be
challenging what's not difficult so Adam
makes a speech where he explains to us
that he cannot explain the difference
between the words difficult and
challenge
they're the same Matt or Adam crap well
can't blame me I waited patiently you
have Matt goes home
bye Matt he was a sweetheart and I knew
that this week was tough
who Eric's had a funny voice I really
liked and then he said life was hard and
you know what he's not wrong so in my
opinion Eric should be sticking around
and then oh we're told we're in France
okay finally I just didn't know where we
were and then there was like this very
Beauty and the Beast fish staircase are
they still doing cross-promotion for
that movie I don't know Adam looks like
he's on Miami Vice and then Adam goes
home okay bye Adam goodbye max goodbye
Adam goodbye Madame Erik still here and
that's the way it should have been no
offense to them but why are you such a
soft place for my heart
so Rachel cried maybe the most she's
ever cried in this episode sending these
guys home because she does keep a 100
and she does heat sending people home
she told me that that was her biggest
fear when I interviewed her during the
Hilton Head date she said she was just
gonna feel bad about sending those
people home yes that was a shameless
plug you can see that interview at TMI
nagham oh then we had a teaser for next
week and this teaser is so good
we had vineyards of islands and
haystacks and castles and rivers and
sunsets and fairy tales and blimps and
as Rachel quitted hometowns can change
everything we can change everything
oh let's drink again for every time you
to work right
[Music]
at all just like the snow this beautiful
hair if this is a fairytale he's a
prince in the Little Mermaid the
Prince's name in oh no it's Erik crap ha
ha ha Wow well okay Erik's the Prince
sure
and I really I was so confident in that
for a second
also you guys in the teaser we see that
Rachel sister questions Bryan Bryan
talks a lot but I don't think there's a
sincerity factor and we see Dean's dad
and I did not see his aesthetic coming
he was a surprise so this show continues
to surprise delight and romanticize us
as a people as a nation as a global
thing everybody thank you so much for
being here please subscribe to et on
Facebook Like us on YouTube you can
watch The Bachelorette live with me
every Monday night I tweet it while
watching it and drinking and again
that's why I don't remember the name of
the Princeton little mermaid love you
all bye look at this stuff isn't it neat
I forgot that his name wasn't Pete in
fact his name is Eric woof I mess up
everything
I really regret not working as a Disney
Princess for a summer that's honestly
what if I would say three regrets I have
in life is what I wanted to try and do
that heywhat desired me by